Let's go for the speed test of this
2nd week at the CSI in Royan y.
Al Dorado was engaged in the 1 star 6 years and this
2nd test was therefore at the helm M.
A to the chronometer of a height of one meter 25.
This is only the second time that Yel Dorado
made 1 speed event,
knowing that the first time was during the first week.
So it's all new to him,
especially since it is 1 horse with 1 style
rather Hunter.
But Yel Dorado and Benoit really took the game.
They turned short
and the horse jumped very well
along the route
despite the conditions that were not obvious.
You can't see much on the video
but the ring was really not with us,
it was raining like crazy,
they finished
completely soaked.
In short,
I am very happy with the horse which is very good
behaved.
If I remember correctly,
there was fairly little no fault that day.
The test was more technical than the day before is
prepared for the next day's grand prize.
Benoît played the clock
but without taking all the risks in the world
and I was very proud to see my horse
on this speed event.
Benoît's strategy
is complicated since it ends
without fail and 4th in the event before the grand prix of the
6 years old the next day